le bonheur c'est de la connerie tu crois
que picasso était heureux tu crois
qu'hemingway aussi aucune oeuvre d'art
digne de ce nom n'a jamais été créés
grâce au bonheur ça je peux te garantir
c'est pour ça qu'on est tous deux
misérables trou du cul alors tu sais que
tu es un misérable trou du cul tu crois
que je suis idiot
bien sûr je le sais il n'y a plus qu'un
seul labo dans le monde qui développe
les kodachrome etc dwayne's photo a
personne comme ça votre père a retrouvé
quatre pellicule ce qu'il a fait il ya
très longtemps et il veut que vous le
convier là bas je lui ai pas parlé
depuis plus de dix ans il et nous rend
toi il va bientôt faire nu et away tu
viens aussi sauf si tu veux me faire ma
piqûre c'est un des plus grands
photographes ont encore en vie
je me souviens de chaque photo que j'ai
pris ce temps à oublier aucune nom alors
je suis né le combien le 19 février le
19 février
oubliez c'est un [ __ ] dis toi que
c'est pas ton père prenez la route 80
ouais si vous voulez bien me donner ce
truc
qu'est ce que tu fais on prend la route
touristique
[Musique]
fêtez votre chambre ouais on peut dire
beaucoup de choses sur le passé de
quelqu'un et grâce à la musique il a
écouté le dire je perde en font tous
remonter c'est pas comme ça que je vois
je ne me suis jamais imaginé que j'étais
un bon mari ni un bon père
c'était super 8
ça n'apporte rien au monde toujours
ressasser le passé
[Musique]
j'ai baissé les bras tellement de fois
dans ma vie je suis fatigué de fatigue
on prend des photos pour arrêter le
temps tiens
et figé des instants pour l'éternité
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as décidé de faire ce voyage
je voulais voir si tu étais bien au
niveau de ce gros [ __ ] que j'ai
détesté toute ma vie es tu me trouves
comment marc lucas torrent un minable
aubaine ed
[Musique]